Hepler or as I prefer to call him mr.
Ivor Braun hashtag feminism hashtag
Hitler died 70 years ago last month
which is apparently long enough for some
countries to get away with TV shows like
this but a new Czech Republic TV show
has pushed the reality TV genre even
closer to the edge of good taste with a
new Nazi themed show called holiday in
the Protectorate the premise is simple
three generations of one family are
placed in a situation of a mock Nazi
occupied Europe
if they make it through two months they
get 50 grand but that begs so many
questions not the least of which is what
happens if they don't with what does
losing entail on that show because in
1939 the states were pretty high
now you might think that is the most
casual use of Nazi history you can
possibly imagine but there's actually
been something that we've been wanting
to show to you for a while a couple of
months ago we were researching a story
and stumbled across a propaganda video
produced by the Thai government designed
to teach the core values of Thai society
just keep an eye out for what one child
is painting
[Music]
yes that is a child applauding their
friends Hitler painting which is
obviously offense if you don't applaud
art when you like it you not
thoughtfully and drink you're waiting
complimentary gallery shot tonight
now we naturally assumed that this was
just a one-off aberration but it turns
out Thailand has something of a bizarre
fixation with Hitler imagery Thailand's
biggest university apologizing today for
a controversial mural take a look at the
artwork it's depicting Adolf Hitler and
a group of superheroes a Christian
school in Thailand now apologizing for
allowing students to march in a Nazi
themed parade the Hitler chicken
restaurant is using an image of the Nazi
leader on an emblem similar to KFC KFC
calls it extremely distasteful that's
right
KFC the makers of the chicken scraps and
potato melons you drink from a cup pull
something extremely distasteful and were
not being hypocritical now to be fair in
Thai schools world history is not given
much attention with little or no mention
of the Holocaust although to be even
fairer come on how is it appropriate to
use Hitler on a billboard to advertise a
wax museum or to advertise a herbal
laxative tea with Hitler proclaiming
release the demon that doesn't even make
sense Thailand if you add Hitler
screaming at you to take a I'm
pretty sure he wouldn't need a
laxative
and we haven't even got into the
clothing available in Thailand yet you
can buy t-shirts featuring panda
Hitler's and Teletubby Hitler's who is
that last one for there are two types of
people who would wear Hitler Teletubby
clothing the type that wants a Teletubby
shirts so badly they'll take one with
Hitler on it and the type who wants a
Hitler shirt so badly they'll take one
with the Teletubby on it and I'm not
sure who the worst person is there but
the greatest example of just how
comfortable Thailand is with Hitler
imagery is the fact that a toy band
called slur once produced this video
that is misjudged just from a marketing
standpoint how a teenage girl supposed
to pick a favorite boy band member if
all of them are the bad boy
look look Thailand you need to
understand the only acceptable
depictions of Hitler are either in a
history textbook or accidentally on a
dog's face that's the only time who's a
bad boy
you are you're a very bad boy but to
embrace the actual Hitler is a real
problem he was terrible
Google Hitler right now Thailand and see
what comes up seriously
do it now we will all wait
[Music]
yes exactly Thailand he was really bad
look this has to stop because if you
need a charismatic personality with a
funny mustache to worship there are
other options in fact there's a perfect
option and I'm talking about beloved
comedian and TV personality Rip Taylor
he's got everything you're looking for
Thailand funny moustache check colorful
outfits big check what about a flair for
pageantry Rip Taylor ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
sure it's no Nuremberg rally but come on
it's pretty cokes and the beauty is Rip
Taylor is more than willing to be the
new face of whatever you want in
Thailand don't take my word for it
tell them rip Thailand I would love to
be your substitute Hitler I would love
to be your substitute Hitler would Rip
Taylor on whatever you want murals and
and walls and t-shirts and chicken
restaurants and dress up your boy bands
as me seriously Rip Taylor Rip Taylor
has never killed six million Jews tell
the grip never killed a single Jew
seriously no never never it's not my
nature
exactly and to be honest that's a relief
because I did not check that before
asking him but the point is is true so
come on Thailand because if anything
your laxative teas are about to get even
better commercials that's our show are
huge thanks to rip tighten the police
join us next week good luck we know the
difference between this show and make
you pay dude my tube phase more likely
to stay on hope you learn about politics
I did
you